here's what drives me crazy the when
somebody goes like like start making
your case watches make a case start
arguing with me what is it what was the
problem you have with me but you never
pick up anything your Wow yeah I wasn't
done talking Wow I wasn't done talking
that's amazing
would you like to keep talking or what
when you're ready to hear with always go
oh [ __ ] ah that that that Wow oh you
make sure get in with your sniffing oh
they're so strange yet estranged are you
not even over we had a barbecue like
fortune i barbecue a bunch of people
over and there's this you know there's
like normal fourth of July [ __ ]
there's guacamole there's salsa this
chip there's just your normal stuff all
sudden there's a bowl of peanuts on it
like the peanuts are you correct like
with the shell on yeah one of those is
peanuts here but one thing there doesn't
belong like it's like you know it's like
already and I went why would you put
peanuts on right there baby stop
freeze-frame right there because I've
done this right there i can you can
anybody would walk in and go like this
one they should freeze-frame the thing
and go now to the crevice where Brendon
should really say they look great
instead now healthy I don't feel it
being passes me like all good it doesn't
make sense I went we can have peanuts I
don't think they should be in the same
order next week what more in salsa I
think I put them over there also the
shells in the house don't make sense I'm
sorry does this look like a Texas
Roadhouse we should throw the peanuts on
the ground it doesn't look like to me I
also grew up American is [ __ ] and we
don't have peanuts at a barbecue I'm
gonna take these peanuts from somewhere
else
matter of fact should I just get rid of
the peanut got all-american barbecue
time not an elephant not an elephant
don't have a trunk I'm sorry did we hire
an elephant why are the peanuts by the
Saltine now if it didn't make sense yeah
it makes no sense now how did that work
out for you yeah you know yeah not well
no I know okay not well it's just that
but it's like you sure I don't like it
it's like a fourth of July barbecue
there's a symphony here I got burgers on
the grill this channel
there's some hotdogs Oh what's this
cherry pie that makes sense
iced tea cold beer salsa clock chip yay
peanuts hog well why are the Korean ribs
next to the hummus peanuts with Sheldon
suck-ass oh it's like a relic how's it
going why are you throwing peanuts shell
game a night no matter even if you try
to eat them even if NASA had machinery
and they were breaking the kids there's
always [ __ ] that falls on the floor I'm
sorry are we gonna dodge it you have all
the knowledge but I do make it all a
repository my brains you could see my
blood that your voice gets weak about
knowledge just bring it down a little
pan squeeze a little I like let's quit a
little squared I just I just want to
because knowledge can be scary sometimes
and I'm trying to criticize I understand
now I'm gonna stay whatever soda right I
do want to say before you walked in that
Brendan was saying that my chest was a
little more manly than yours I'll say he
has the best body comedy I'm so and so I
just wanted to make sure you have heard
that first you sell out Dublin in
Ireland that quick and I know he did UK
and then you got to talk about his body
will this [ __ ] I'm Brian day today you
guys you have a pot off what they're
working on but there's no time doing
more incline bench now so get ready for
my okay I'll tell he's so been doing
right I do I went bought I think no no
no before you got before you got here
tell already
Brendan literally said I just got to get
him to do some meat pie yeah I don't
like a bagel I don't have the bird cage
he's like yeah he goes I'll buy it for
him I just want him to do some marijuana
and you walked in the door like my man
I've been telling up forever
well I went on him as I feel he because
you just got to get the shove more
inclined loser 50 year old Amazon bench
I'll get the better one not even the
better one yeah cuz you know in case it
breaks down I put it together myself
which is incredible I can't do anything
like that listen I bought the way and
now I do I do in fact today I swear guys
I walk in the pocket I go I'm gonna do
incline today right so you see it all
right I sure I'm not sure so I don't put
on muscle I just don't I'm an ectomorph
alright well then you're just the bones
will get bigger though the bull you'll
be like an exoskeleton I've got a little
bit of trouble
you gonna yeah you could have the best
exoskeleton in comedy is that what is
that what is that what we're going for
to grow is to grow our skeletons well he
said that's all the growth that's a
maggot look like a like a bum it's funny
the creditor we come from a generation
where we're always going to be in shape
all of us I think right we all hold onto
our vanity but like my father's
generation if you look at them they just
simply let themselves the [ __ ]
generation different because obesity has
never been well that's true but that
might be that's true actually because
you're living in a calorie you're in LA
and we're Litella for dreams have never
been this it's just a whole lot more
extremes now right well they're they're
people who are in incredible shape but
also the extreme on the other end is
noticing my six on plan life have you
ever been to Walmart anywhere in the
south go dude this is my like Rob Lowe
and I'm like I'm gonna hang out
everybody
Rob oh you look pretty would you say
hello oh it's so [ __ ] painful but to
me it's part of the gaming to me what
and this is what made one of the reasons
fighting the kid such a loyal following
is I got the mic next dammit this how I
feel this [ __ ] sucks
I tried I came up short what do you want
me to do on to the next one yeah what
you can't do is go oh my god I lost I'm
going to go to the darkness I don't want
to see anyone I don't want to talk about
it because then what what example are
you setting for people go oh you lost
you think you're bald go home but that
that's easy for us to say but humans are
what we are were complex and were you
know were flawed you know Saranda that's
just how she could that's all she could
muster
yeah yeah I mean that yeah that's so
that those are her demons to deal with
you know and she's doing the best she
can you know yeah you know I think most
people say it's not working again if
that's what works for her doesn't matter
she does it oh that's just thing you
don't owe anyone any fat set so maybe
that's what is her world that works for
her yeah real world it doesn't look like
oh well you say you don't owe anyone
anything I agree 100%
like the
seen people like I've said if Cormier
beats Jones he'll retire even read the
only lot and people like he can't retire
it's only one apiece he can do whatever
he wants
I get this all the time kind of I say
you know I've kind of knocked out Floyd
Mayweather
I think he just rides off in the sunset
or maybe maybe he fights Nate Diaz for
the trilogy I 155 the biggest UFC event
ever that's it but those are the only
two fighter every never see could be
never seen Tony Ferguson he'd say and
people like that's not fair he owes it
to us to fight a guy like could be even
time like does he does why would he know
you exactly why would he just take his
nine figure payday and [ __ ] all this and
just go off and raise his son and do
Hollywood movie